you know as we enter the new year i
thought it'd be it'd be fun to take a
trip down memory lane and review some of
the feminists that we've uh watched some
of the feminist comedians we've watched
over the last year not really fun i mean
not fun's not the right word it's
actually deeply traumatic for me but
maybe fun for you to watch me in my pain
you uh use sadists so we're going to
start with the feminist comedians uh you
know scare quotes around comedians
samantha b and lily singh now both of
these women were it might seem equally
unfunny but i think now's the time to
see who who wins the actual title of the
worst feminist comedian period of all
time period so first up let's check out
samantha b
so my producer suggested that i watch
and review some feminist comedy bits
and he he suggested this because
evidently he hates my guts which is
understandable i i would hate me too if
i wasn't me i in me and i hate me so you
know
but uh the thing is i did actually watch
some feminist comedy in in anticipation
of doing this little youtube video and
uh but but much of it was so bad i'm a
feminist and usually like i'm um i'm
like not an advocate of like street
harassment and stuff like that um except
from men that wear gray track suits
just so so
so bad i remember when kate middleton
announced her pregnancy
i was like i wonder if she'll keep it
who knows
that i thought maybe the fruit was
hanging a little too low a little too
little it's a little too easy and
there's all kinds of euphemism packed
into that last sentence that you can get
into later but then i thought if i'm
going to review feminist comedy i
shouldn't go for the obscure ones i
should focus on a feminist comedian who
is successful
well-known
allegedly talented and that's why i am
going to focus on samantha b you know
samantha b has her own comedy show on
lifetime or whatever it's on and she's
hailed by the media as brilliant and
hilarious and genius and so on that's
what the media says about her i figure
she's the best of the best when it comes
to woke female comedians so let me give
her a shot we're going to watch some
samantha bee
together and
more than reviewing it i think
i want to see if i can find a reason to
laugh
i want to laugh at a samantha bee joke i
want to see if i can do that today
i'll try my hardest
so let's watch this together let's start
with this we'll take a look okay
[Music]
meatpacking workers often contend with
cramped conditions grueling labor and
long hours so it's unsurprising that
plants have become hot spots for covet
19.
if we want to keep our food supply safe
we should first keep our workers safe so
naturally the president isn't following
aggressive lobbying from the meat
industry trump issued an executive order
aimed at reopening meat processing
plants look it's not shocking the
president leapt into action to save meat
because burgers
you endanger girl
okay um
so i think there are some jokes in there
i can't be sure
and this might be part of samantha bee's
genius that she tells she tells jokes
and and nobody knows that they're jokes
so she's deconstructing comedy that's
what i'm told that's the thing about
female comedians
samantha b hannah gatsby
they're always deconstructing comedy
rather than just
telling funny jokes and i don't mean to
imply that women aren't funny i would
never imply that i in fact in
stating it explicitly
just kidding not really but sort of
okay let's keep going from ohio to new
york michigan to california this morning
the beef shortage at wendy's is
spreading the company with that
unforgettable catchphrase decades ago is
now having trouble finding the beef
you're out of beef then out of paddy's
it's embarrassing that the where's the
beef place is out of beef it'd be like
if someone at taco bell was caught
thinking inside the bun
okay
let's stop right there
this is a professional comedian folks
she makes millions of dollars
telling jokes
and yet she's never actually told one so
far as i can tell
so i'm starting to figure out that that
when people say samantha b is funny
which i've never actually heard anyone
say that but theoretically
if they do say that they don't mean it
on the scale of comedians right they
they're using a different scale what
they mean is that she's funny
for a feminist
which is like saying like a corn dog is
healthy for carnival food it's just it's
so maybe if we understand it on that
scale we get into the mind of a feminist
maybe it becomes funny so let's uh
let's keep going
with some food shortages and increased
prices the federal supplemental
nutrition assistance program is more
necessary than ever about 38 million
people rely on snap benefits to feed
their families and last month the usda
announced it would increase overall
benefits 40 percent to give families
more money to buy food unfortunately
many food stamp households were left out
of the benefit expansion because they
were already receiving the maximum
amount now while democrats are trying to
raise benefits by 15 percent republicans
are attempting to block that change just
for context the maximum benefit for a
family of four is only
646 dollars per month for republicans
giving hungry families an extra hundred
bucks during a worldwide pandemic is too
big of an ask both because they deeply
passionately don't give about poor
people and because steve mnuchin needs
it to fashion sheets for his bed
my god
my god in heaven deliver me lord
if you feel like you're not getting the
respect you deserve in life um well that
might be because you don't have a title
in front of your name that
causes people forces people to respect
you and here's here's something that you
could get you could get established
titles uh your very own proclamation
like i have declaring that you are a
lord or lady and you have this and you
will gain the respect you deserve i
guarantee you all you need is this one
square foot plot of land in scotland and
established titles is a project based on
a historic scottish custom where
landowners are referred to as lairds or
lords and ladies in english in your
title pack which i hold in my hand here
you'll receive at least one square foot
of dedicated land on a private estate
and an official certificate with a crest
your certificate will include a unique
plot number with which you can see the
exact location of your land with this
certificate you could officially change
your name to lord or lady and you get on
your credit card you're playing tickets
so this is like a legal name change i am
legally officially
lord matt walsh lord best-selling
children's author matt walsh establish
titles is having a great limited time
sale so go to
com establishtitles.com matt walsh to
save 10 off today remember to use the
discount code matt walsh or just click
the link below that's established titles
dot com slash matt walsh or just click
the link below
yeah really i i forgot how terrible she
was i i think i blocked that out of my
memory and a lot of these
suppressed memories are coming back from
my subconscious i think that's gonna be
hard to beat but let's see if lily singh
has what it takes to earn the title of
the worst feminist comedian
so i've been i've been putting this off
for a long time months ago i began my
quest to find a funny feminist comedian
well not even a funny feminist comedian
actually because the bar is lower than
that i just they don't need to be funny
all the time or even most of the time i
just need to find a feminist comedian
who can make me laugh one time i want
just one laugh that's all i'm asking for
i don't even need them to be funny twice
just one time
and so far i've come up empty so i tried
to laugh at samantha b uh instead i
nearly died of boredom i tried to laugh
at hannah gadsby and said i was
depressed for three days afterwards
tried to laugh at chelsea handler and
instead i left only feeling very
concerned i'm not suicidal you don't
have to worry about it i did not laugh
at any of their jokes or even come close
to laughing so today
i'm getting back on the horse and we're
gonna try to ride this thing to victory
today i will try to laugh at one of the
newest uh comedy sensations
in the female comedy space her name is
lily singh
she was a popular youtuber who then
became a late night host
i just found out about her existence
two days ago so that's how plugged in i
am to everything she replaced apparently
carson daly carson daly has had a job on
television for about 73 years a little
mummy reference a little joan rivers put
them together it's funny it's not easy
to fill those shoes is what i'm saying
lily singh is trying
feminists love her she's a big star
apparently maybe she's the one who can
crack the code let's find out we'll
start with uh this is a bit she did on
international women's day i am pumped
because this sunday we're celebrating
international women's day y'all
now don't worry you don't have to
remember to go out and get anyone
flowers
you just have to remember to go out and
fight for equal pay for women in the
workplace
i think it's by the checkout at cvs
now i know there are guys out there
thinking
international women's day why don't we
have an international men's day
god bless you twitter well you're in
luck because you do it's actually on
november 19th
but you wouldn't know that because
you're too busy celebrating it every
other day of the year
[Applause]
why do i do this to myself
why do i
do this i don't i'm i'm just doubting my
own life choices this is the level of
humor that we're we're starting with
every day is men's day our heart
it's so unoriginal and witless that you
may as well not say anything
there's no point of even making the joke
if that's if it's between making no joke
or pulling a joke from a facebook meme
from five years ago then you may as well
make no joke at all you may as well get
up there for your monologue and just
stare blankly into the camera that would
be significantly funnier than this so
far by the way you're damn right lady
every day is is men's day every day is
my day as a man you are damn right
every day could be your day too if you
just went out and asserted yourself
instead of whining about sexism and
being so damn focused on how everyone
else feels about you you know when you
sit around demanding that other people
affirm you and celebrate you if that's
how you live your life then yeah you get
one day of the year that's all you get
i take every day i go and take it okay
not funny so far but maybe this will get
better let's keep listening
also
fun fact november 19th is also
international toilet day
now i'm not i'm not saying men are
toilets but
both holidays are mostly catered towards
a bunch of white johns
oh my god
oh my god lord save me deliver me from
this trial
white johns
that joke made the cut consider this
okay this is a late night show
presumably they have some kind of
writer's room you wouldn't know it from
the material but i assume they do so
there were a bunch of jokes that didn't
make it to air
right they actually threw out jokes
because they were worse than that
maybe there's a brilliant writer in that
room
probably a man let's be honest no
offense it could be the second coming of
richard pryor in that room
writing material and maybe her sense of
humor is so bad that she throws those
out the brilliant material should i like
that white john's though that is killer
let's do that this is the female
equivalent of basically a dad joke
but dad jokes don't work unless they're
coming from a dad i don't mean to be
sexist but you got to be a man to pull
him off you can't do a dad joke in a
dress is what i'm trying to say
i feel like not enough people know about
international women's day i remember i
asked one guy if he knew what iwd is and
he said yeah can you believe george bush
lied about them being in iraq
what are you talking about
according to wikipedia international
women's day is only an official holiday
in 26 countries and wait for it the us
is not one of them that's right
essentially it's the difference between
how i'm treated on this show and how i'm
treated when i try to get a drink at a
bar
what
lily you don't have to do this to
yourself you really don't you had a good
thing going you had a good life yeah
your youtube channel you're making money
this is so bad that carson daly
is starting to look charismatic by
comparison people are actually pining
now for the comedic genius of carson
daly
that's how bad this is
maybe that was the the plan all along by
nbc maybe they were they just brought
her in
to make people appreciate carson daly
more i don't know do you know why
international women's day isn't an
official holiday in the u.s because it's
stupid why would we have a holiday to
celebrate women yes celebrate certain
women if you want to be celebrated go
out and do something to be celebrated
for
not just because you're a woman that's
not an accomplishment to be one
tell a funny joke lily
that'd be an achievement you tell a
funny joke and uh i will i i will i will
name a holiday after you i'll build you
a statue i'll name a galaxy after you
just tell one funny joke that's all i
ask yeah i think both are
in my opinion equally horrible as i
expected them to be so it's kind of a
difficult choice to make but since i'm
being forced to choose one um i if i
have to choose
i think the winner of the worst feminist
comedian title
would
have to belong to
samantha bee i think i i think i got to
give it to her in the end she is she's
the uber feminist comedian and the worst
of the lie but you can leave your
comments below and let me know what you
think